Nice. Yes, sir.
Student Activities and
I've had love.
mist for the light.
It all works.
Okay.
B-O-S.
Can it e-work?
a lot of project lead-up, Ulta Hudal internil.
so on.
Hello. Eidel.
And, Learner B5 Adi is, it's an addi
Well, it's Bakashvil Hayao
Gamed, named hello out.
Anishat Said.
With a healthy internship full-time. E a software house.
Thank you.
Quala Muhammad, the Muhammad had him.
Okay.
Uh… .
And, uh, nice thing about.
Okay, okay. And I go to Shekik Vote.
Uh, how much is an article heads up and his friends internally.
internship.
I'll share my screen.
11th green, sir.
Okay. Hello.
which
business simulation.
virtual.
social company.
Okay, if the whole way could get out far right. Hello. Mesh.
Learning Journey
and the learners, data buoyancy deal interactions that. Eval evaluation,
Virtual Internship.
real work experience. Real work experience is there.
Ann
Especially,
experience.
Need develop experiences.
option hotelista
Nish.
Seba, Aramundra PD
Nice.
Gotcha.
Okay, and after,
So fast
And the first time fixed matter. Okay.
We,
Sure.
It's actually users want to throw the data
talking to users in Sarah.
A point of view, hello, mesi.
trust the data, and our actual users whom…
Ah,
I've reached.
One teacher done perfectly, or three features done well enough. Three features done well enough.
Requirements,
Hello.
Venezuela, last question B2B.
What's aboveen, what something new.
Okay.
sample uma pagan nakedam in many of the groups will naked sur lenta te ha mil customer behavior yang hasa mo dabit
Hello, Mesh. Hello, Mesh. Yes.
It is.
I will note our feature first and fix later can Mark Zuckerberga Facebook feature
El mesh, well
Ka
Talban users.
Oh.
Scrum methodology.
Get them.
It should come with that.
By the ability.
Kwais.
And it's all about workers
Good.
Okay.
And, um…
kind of like a secret mocking research more, past semiseni.
And yes, and with the business model yours, I will market my lawyers.
And again with me, Shev.
Oh,
I guess a new…
One abandona is disakullah.
Hello, I didn't have a question.
Oh.
Uh… one feature, huh?
L.
Uh…
broke the old…
Nice.
Hell.
We do still want a B2B.
Ms. Sheffey?
I, the
Oh, yes, huh?
Themicelliage.
Okay, nice.
Uh, remember.
And another way.
I gave him a picture. Bas.
And I feel like
With our areas.
Amesh.
Okay.
Hi, the voice.
I've got friends.
Ma'am?
Uh…
Anna, after that
Wish.
There are 3 features
Hello, Mesh.
Okay, perfectly mesh.
Oh
Nice.
It will be Halloween.
Mistakes.
groups live data
For early stages.
perfectly.
results.
something already broken
Okay.
out of experience.
Let's good
Thank you.
Okay, alright, wish.
Okay. Mesh.
Walt Royok.
Oh, I can win with them.
Ma'am, and I'm also why okay.
Anna Shiv fast and fix later.
This is Delta Bushhip for stock today.
B2C or B2B, an B2C aksa obkassivia.
Let's, uh, the wind is ready.
You are my perfect fear, and had multi B2C, that's okay, fine
Okay. Messi.
Globally, at least completion wait.
mindset.
The news or time may lose some interviews, Tamil stakeholders, uh, stakeholders. El podag manager.
And…
Thank you.
discovery question.
Oh, yes.
In both extens.
Yeah, an Amazon product sense, Amazon product manager, hotelfront developer, lower developer, and resources. I'm product manager.
Okay.
By utilization.
Okay. Our old valley, I think.
Oh, ooh.
developer will…
When this might be for Quru for Lahmoudi.
CEOs but for cost strategy.
We have a cost strategy.
Let me show you.
Outlook without mesh.
Okay, Mesh.
solution espace.
Like in Bella Winta.
For fashion kid in talisman, Minhino Warrior, if you have the Olach feature.
For example…
business.
Hello, Karamda.
Perfect.
Uh…
Hello Kellam. Week 1. Week 1, Badam and problem statement about weekly strategy week.
Week 3? Le.
Fin.
Managers,
In high tweaks with that demo solution visualized a full functional solution, right?
Week 4. Keda.
When we do physical internship.
And then the design metrics or dashboard where Yanni, Ash and the solution management.
We at Advantage Sprint retrospective, we attend users quickly developer.
Alfiniani.
It's an LLM?
Mentor B.
problem.
Mish.
I want to save in the screen?
Idahoa.
Amish.
objective
Which feedback loop?
Oh, .
And I'm thinking Netflix Zoom session, duh?
Nice.
I have athletes training also? Okay, yes.
Oh, I understand no.
Dukovi.
about the Google Meet, but…
Nice.
No, it's nadao, uh…
Muchat?
Why the…
No, I mean, okay.